there's growing international pressure
for a ceasefire in the conflict over the
disputed nagorno-karabakh
region in the caucasus france russia and
the u.s are all calling for a hold in
fighting between
armenian and azerbaijani forces a
flare-up in the conflict began at the
end of september and has cost more than
250 lives on both sides
you'll hear from representative from
armenia in just a moment to first
a report explaining what's behind this
decades old conflict
the heavy military presence in
nagorno-karabakh is part of everyday
life in the enclave
as is death and mourning for people on
both sides of the conflict
in recent years the disputed region has
seen fighting flair on a regular basis
located in the south caucasus
nagorno-karabakh is internationally
recognized as part of azerbaijan
but is controlled by ethnic armenian
forces backed by
armenia the conflict dates back to the
dissolution of the soviet union
ever since armenia and azerbaijan have
claimed nagorno-karabakh as their own
territory
a so-called frozen conflict that remains
unresolved four decades later
in july hostilities flared up again 16
people were killed in the fighting
the conflict has international
ramifications turkey has expressed its
support of azerbaijan
while russia has provided armenia with
military equipment
while world leaders are calling for
de-escalation it seems on the ground the
warring sides are fanning the flames of
their frozen conflict
well let's explore this further with the
group ruben rabinian he's a member of
the
parliament in the national assembly of
armenia and head of this standing
committee on international relations
welcome to dw um last week your foreign
minister said it was ready to a the
country was
ready to engage with the oh organization
for security and cooperation in
europe to establish a ceasefire why
hasn't that happened
that hasn't happened for a very simple
reason
the two aggressors azerbaijan
and turkey do not want ceasefire
they do they want to continue the war
and they want to
create a situation of ethnic cleansing
in nagorno-karabakh with a view to what
i have to go back a bit to explain
in the beginning of the 20th century
there were
millions of armenians in turkey now
there are almost no armenians in turkey
up until the end of the 20th century
there were
at least half a million armenians in
azerbaijan there are virtually
no armies in azerbaijan and the only
reason that
armenians still do live in nago no kaaba
is that they
managed to win the war in the 1990s
now it is evident that on the 27th of
september
azerbaijan with full physical
and political support and also military
support of turkey by using terrorists
transported from northern syria
by turkey attacked the people of
nagorno-karma
and i think so the
the thing is when you so you you've
given us the the background
as you see to this this uh supposed
ethnic cleansing but
the rest of the world looks on and
wonders how far
are are your two countries uh from
all-out war at the moment
it's a it's a it's a conflict that has
brewed out of a skirmish
that has been bubbling as you say for
decades but
how how long before this becomes an
actual war
i think you are mistaken we are in a
full
scale war nagorno-karabakh armenians are
in a full-scale war with
uh a tripartite
pact of azerbaijan turkey and terrorists
it's a full-scale war everything is used
airplanes
missiles tanks
drones they are new shelling cities in
nagorno-karabakh
they are using cluster bombs there have
been civilian deaths in armenia proper
not
agronomy the republic of armenia proper
the attack
and let's talk let's talk about those
those deaths because
you have both sides of this uh conflict
armenia and azerbaijan have accused the
other
of uh civilian deaths and you've also
been uh
condemned by the united states and
russia and france
both sides for causing civilian deaths
so why is that happening
um i already told you there's no
i'm talking i'm talking about why is
armenia
killing civilians armenia
is not killing civilians there has been
no single shot
fired from the territory of the republic
of armenia
so why is it then that the united states
russia and france
accuse accuse armenia directly
of uh killing civilians and attacking
um uh civilians outside nagorno-karabakh
regarding nagorno-karabakh the
azerbaijani armed forces
started shelling towns and villages
in nagorno-karabakh including the
capital of stefano
and after many times that the
president of nagorno-karabakh urged
azerbaijanis to stop
shelling civilian populations
the nagorno-karabakh armed forces had to
launch some strikes
at military i repeat military
targets in azerbaijan right
okay and yet as i say civilians appear
to have been
killed but for now we will leave it
there and we thank you for joining us uh
rubin
a rubinian are from the national
assembly of armenia
you